rencontre capitale ce samedi 28 octobre
pour versailles les joueurs de la cité
royale en blanc recevait le leader
invaincu créteil lusitanos
après une entame de match poussive les
versets et qui restait sur deux
victoires consécutives ont réussi à
marquer dès la 20e minute de jeu
ils ont ensuite maîtrisé la fin de la
première période grâce à une tactique
établie avant le match et comptines ces
données confirment donc continuer à bien
travailler ensemble a bien bossé dans le
bloc réduire les espaces avoir une
fonction quand on n'a pas la balle nous
on a respecté des coulissement respecter
des couvertures et ensuite quand on a le
ballon bain bien analysées pour savoir
si on peut se projeter ou bien préparer
encore avec une qualité technique à
chaque instant au retour des vestiaires
versailles baisse de rythme créteil
lusitanos est proche d'égaliser sur
penalty mais c'est finalement à 15
minutes du coup de sifflet final que la
défense versailles et se fait surprendre
sur une erreur malheureusement une
situation qui nous pénaliser tout payant
qu'on paye cher donc et qui amenuise un
peu tout le travail qui a été réalisé
depuis le début du match pour ça que
c'est des joueurs qui s'entraînent
régulièrement matin après midi et soir
donc ils ont peut-être plus de jeux de
jus dans les jambes
après je pense qu'ils ont aussi monté
d'intensité et on a vu par l'entraîneur
je pense qu'il aurait aussi aussi haussé
le ton contre ans vont à la mi temps
donc on a senti une petite différence
mais je pense que c'est aussi dû à un
petit peu de la fatigue est gros et avec
le gros travail qu'on a fourni en
première mi temps malgré un carton rouge
pour créteil lusitanos dans les
dernières minutes de la rencontre le
score n'évoluera plus un but partout
score final content et pas comprendre
par rapport à
par rapport au résumé du match mais bon
après voilà c'est le football
voilà on aurait préféré gagner surtout
quand on est à domicile et voilà c'est
comme ça quand je travaillais tout au
long de la saison
avec ce résultat verset remonte au
classement et occupe désormais la 10e
place à six points du podium prochain
match ce dimanche 5 novembre contre les
us toujours à domicile
[Musique]